c'est une grosse étape et on sait très
bien chaque année il ya deux coups
dégâts et de très bonnes et que notre
corps donc demain et c'est parce
qu'aucun peur et à ce moment et on a
beaucoup de rebondissements à l'arrivée
ce sont les vainqueurs potentiels selon
vous il faudra dire que bon la
guadeloupe ne se fait plus le piéger
parce que depuis la première étape qui
se sont fait piéger il était obligé de
cravacher et a depuis là ils ont tous
joué un homme devant on a vu aujourd'hui
il faut en troisième avec nine et donc
demain avant qu'on est là et il ya aussi
bon dans la vie d'un pilote in qui a
fait un petit peu de zéro aujourd'hui et
pour l'équipe
ils sont venus pour gagner le tour donc
il faut pas oublier que tanis la nisa a
gagné l'an dernier
il va essayer de récidiver cette année
une baisse commencera demain matin sur
le fond d impression depuis le début du
tour en france on sent qu'il est bien
est un costaud il est il est là il faut
dire que kiki qui délivre métropole et
il conduit une catégorie supérieure la
note dans ce qui fait que mon arrivée
ici les biens et la plus belle il voit
dans la mitaine avec tout le monde sait
c'est ça sa chance pense que c'est une
étape de montagne il ya un bon grimpeur
il va pas laisser passer personne il va
s'accrocher et en montagne a pas
question de recours équipiers c'est le
meilleur qui passe quoi